so the democrats will never let go of
covet they just will not let go of it is
their favorite thing in the entire world
because it allows them to restructure
everything it's time for a great reset
it's not just about building back the
economy it's about it's about building
it back better it's not just about
achieving prosperity it's about
achieving justice social justice it's
not just about getting people back to
work it's about people never going back
to work so alexander ocasio-cortez
she was struck by the plague while she
was in sunny florida she came down to
florida for a vacation like the good
responsible person she is
and she unmasked and then because this
is a dystopian hellscape down here in
florida to which she vacation she got
covered
and then she did her quarantine for five
days and then she issued a missive on
instagram a very important message from
alexander ocasio-cortez so fresh
so face so brilliant so magnificent
unthinkably
special
here was her here was her message
quote welt so it happened god covet
probably omicron
as of today i am thankfully recovered
and wrapping up quarantine but covid was
no joke
for a while i've noted the term mild is
misleading when the bar is
hospitalization and death
no that's not misleading that's that's
very often how we characterize disease
if you didn't go to the hospital and you
didn't die
and you recovered within a few days
that's pretty mild
says even mild cases can result in long
covet which includes a range of
conditions like cognitive impairment
pots and chronic fatigue
this isn't to be a downer or induced
fear just a reminder we need to be
careful n95s in crowded indoor spaces
like stores and if you do get it it's
key to take care for yourself and rest
um okay so first of all i noticed that
you were in florida
i noticed that
and you were at like giant events with
other humans breathing on them which is
how you got omicron in the first place
also does she have any stats on how many
of these cases result in long covet from
omicron
she does not
it is to induce fear that is the entire
goal is to induce fear but the real
thing that she is saying is that even
when you're not all that sick you are
super duper sick this is where she's
about to go
the idea of forcing people to work just
five days after symptoms start is
sociopathic and 100 informed by a
culture that accepts sacrificing human
lives for profit margins as a fair trade
okay so first of all
no one is generally forcing people to go
to work
if they are heavily symptomatic from
kovid if you're like hacking up a lung
in other people's face people generally
don't want you at work
but as a general rule the idea that
people are dying in mass numbers because
they are going to work after five days
of quarantine from covet is insane
that's crazy towns first of all omicron
is a very unserious form of the disease
generally speaking it is 90 less deadly
than delta
second of all if you're young and
healthy as aoz presumably is she was
never going to die from omicron
thirdly the measurement of five days
after symptoms start is the minimum
okay if you have symptoms that continue
you are supposed to stay home
finally the symptoms that are associated
with omicron very often are asymptomatic
or so mild that you don't even test for
them a huge number of people probably
had omicron and didn't even know it
that's not sacrificing human lives for
profit margins
and what is she even talking about and
by the way if you took her really really
seriously that you could never quote
unquote sacrifice human lives for profit
margins et cetera et cetera we should
ban cars right because the fact is that
a huge number of people on the roads
kill each other every single year in car
accidents the reason we allow people to
drive at high rates of speeds on
freeways is because people need to go to
work it turns out that part of living a
fulfilled life
is being able to obtain products and
services at a price that you prefer to
pay part of that ensures that you have a
labor force and part of having a labor
force means that you have to take risks
in daily life but according to aoc you
should never have to take a risk in
daily life
ever ever ever
sacrificing human lives i'm sorry like
who is sacrificing human lives by going
back to work after five days of omicron
who
also i will note that for the vast
majority of human existence everybody
went to work sick
she's gonna ask you you're in the
audience ever gone to work having a cold
ever like you took a day quill and you
went to work
the answer from 100 of people here is
yes and the answer is not yes because
you were forced to work because if you
didn't work you were going to get fired
that day it's because you didn't feel
like taking a sick day and also because
you know what it's not all that much fun
sitting at home for long periods of time
and not working people generally work
because believe it or not most people
want to work depression rates among the
unemployed particularly the long-term
unemployed are about three times the
rate of the depression rates among the
employed having a job is a fulfilling
part of life for the vast majority of
people which is something that the left
refuses to acknowledge it's something
that nancy pelosi once said nancy pelosi
once said that if people were not wed to
their jobs they could become artists and
musicians now as it turns out
over the course of the pandemic people
were not wed to their jobs they stayed
home they were forced to stay home you
know what they did they got fat and
watched netflix and we're depressed
that's what they did for a year
in blue states they're still doing it
we'll get to more on aoc's dramatic bout
with covid in just one second first
surveillance is only increasing the fact
is the government would like to know
what you do the tech would like to know
what you do to help protect your data
from being tracked by either of those
forces i urge you to get express vpn and
use it the same way that i do it doesn't
matter where you live every time you
search for something online watch a
video or click a link it all gets
tracked by three letter agencies by big
tech or both anytime they want they can
match your activity to your true
identity using your device's unique ip
address but when i turn on expressvpn
they can't see my ip address at all my
identity is anonymized by a secure vpn
server plus expressvpn encrypts 100 of
my internet data for protection from any
eavesdroppers or cyber criminals the
best part was expressvpn makes it super
easy i even had my mom using it the app
literally has one button you open it up
on your phone or computer hit that big
on button to connect that's it you're
protected see check this out i just open
up my phone and then i go to the
expressvpn app there it is it is not
connected but soon it shall be and now i
don't have to worry about big tech or
big government monitoring me so stop
handing over your data to the government
and big tech companies defend your
rights with the same vpn i use visit
expressvpn.com ben shapiro show to get
three extra months for free or click the
link in my description below that's
expressvpn.com ben shapiro show
expressivevpn.com
ben shapiro show
aoc continues if you've noticed much of
the emphasis of media conversations on
covet are individualistic wear a mask
get vaccinated to protect yourself go
back to work even with symptoms because
you're fine even if you're not and while
some of these recommendations are good
like getting a vaccine and wearing masks
were appropriate the motivations for
them shouldn't just be selfish it should
also be because we actually give it him
that other people our disabled neighbors
our co-workers who haven't said and
shouldn't feel obligated to say they're
immunocompromised etc okay like this is
a person who has no
she has no relationship with real life
yeah i mean that picture of her cuddling
with her dog
this is a person who does not have a
relationship with real life she just
does not she lives in a box of her own
making on instagram
and go back to the post for a second
like that is so crazy
that we
what you're supposed to never go out
again because no one should have to say
if they're immunocompromised if you're
immunocompromised you need to take
special precautions to protect yourself
but to expect no one else to ever go to
work without an n95 again because you're
immunocompromised is crazy
and when she says that it's too
individualistic to think about getting
vaccinated to protect yourself here's
the thing i'm in favor of getting
vaccinated to protect other people the
problem is getting vaccinated does not
protect other people
israel has a study out today it shows
that a fourth dose of the vax does not
prevent you from getting omicron
or transmitting it so what is she even
talking about
what is she talking about
the whole point of the vaccines in the
first place is that they were 100
effective this was the original pitch
they were 100 effective
in preventing hospitalization and death
essentially and they were also
effective in preventing transmission
and which meant that if they were
effective in you in preventing death
then you had nobody else's business in
mind right once you were protected you
were protected
when it came to the idea of hurt
immunity that disappeared very quickly
in this pandemic so she's just not
connected with the science at all but
this is she's going somewhere else with
this and where she's going with it with
this is if you don't want to work you
should never have to work again
that is where she continues to go
she continues it's truly bizarre to me
that giving a bleep about other people
is a polarizing political stance but my
dad used to say that life makes you
repeat lessons until you learn them
yeah man if she had taken that lesson to
heart maybe she she would actually
understand economics and if there's one
lesson i think we as a country are
repeating until we learn it's that
community and collective good is our
best shot through our greatest
challenges way more than discorded acts
of rugged individualism and the
bootstrap propaganda we've been spoon
fed since birth yes nothing says success
in an innovative system quite like
the heavy boot of government on your
face forever
amazing well yes what's getting us
through this is the power of the power
of the federal government and state and
local government individualism is
inadequate for planetary forces like
climate change or global pandemics no
less societal ones like healthcare
economic inequity and racism but we as a
collective can confront them in a world
of me's let's build team
wii
heart
yeah man
that lady's gonna run for president i
would bet you dollars to donuts in a
world of me's let's build team wii
oh you're so tiresome
the only person aoc cares about is aoc
she's the most self-obsessed human being
walking the planet today it is
incredible but in a world of mies let's
build team we anyway that's enough for
today stay healthy and blessed and let's
keep building love and solidarity a-o-c
yeah that's that's great individualism
is never a solution to anything
communitarianism is the solution to
healthcare economic inequity racism
climate change global is there anything
collectivism can't do aside from
providing goods and services is an
affordable at an affordable price and
not bankrupting entire economies and
relegating people to uh to utter tyranny
is there anything collectivism isn't
good for we should listen to the uh to
this
brilliant
wonderkind
a truly inspiring figure
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang